Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
La vidéo que je viens de vous dévoiler,
je l’ai filmée en juillet 2019
alors que je tentais le record
de la traversée du chemin royal des Incas.
Imaginez presque
2 000 kilomètres de pistes
avec 35 cols à plus de 4000 m d’altitude
à franchir entre la ville de Cuzco
et la cordillère blanche.
Sur cette expédition, mon corps
subit d'énormes contraintes.
À cette altitude, l’oxygène est deux fois
inférieur à celui du niveau de la mer.
J’ai donc besoin de respirer deux fois
plus pour alimenter mes muscles
Mon sang, qui est pompé et éjecté
par mon cœur
qui bat à 150 pulsations par minute,
s’épaissit.
S'il s'épaissit trop, je risque l'œdème
et potentiellement la mort.
J’ai des crevasses profondes sur les mains
à cause de la température extrême
des -20 degrés qui règne dans les Andes.
J’ai une plaie ouverte sur ma cuisse
à cause d’un cuissard que je n’ai pas pu
changer depuis plus de 10 jours.
Le soleil, l'astre péruvien.
Son indice UV est deux fois supérieur
à celui de la Côte d’Azur.
J’ai donc l’épiderme brûlé.
Pour couronner le tout,
la haute altitude perturbe
mes sens et plonge mon corps
dans une sorte de narcose pour survivre.
La souffrance, elle est tellement
insupportable dans cette expédition
que j’en pleure chaque jour.
En visualisant cette vidéo avec vous,
je me dis que je dois être
un petit peu fou.
Ou en tout cas je m’interroge
sur les raisons qui me poussent
à me plonger dans
des souffrances pareilles.
C'est vrai.
Je pourrais par exemple prendre un 4x4
et aller traverser le chemin des Incas
assisté par un véhicule.
Je pourrais aussi prendre mon smartphone
et regarder les photos sur Internet
derrière un écran ou plus simple,
je pourrais tout simplement ne pas
envisager des expéditions aussi folles.
Puisque c'est super dangereux,
je pourrais me tuer.
Et si la recette secrète du bonheur,
c’était d’apprendre à mieux souffrir ?
Oui, vous avez bien entendu.
Savoir gérer la douleur
pour être plus heureux.
Tentez des défis fous à l’aide d’un vélo,
c’est ma passion,
mais également mon métier.
J’ai eu la chance de traverser
parmi les pistes
les plus incroyables de la planète,
sur les traces des grandes
migrations humaines :
la cordillère des Andes, à deux
reprises, le chemin Royal des Incas,
la route des Rois en Jordanie,
la jungle laotienne.
J’ai traversé des continents,
des environnements hostiles,
en autonomie complète et en plongeant
mon corps aux limites du possible.
Ce qui va peut-être vous surprendre
en revanche,
c’est que quelques années en arrière,
j’étais assis, dans cette salle,
comme vous,
et j’étais à mille lieues
d’imaginer que ma vie allait basculer.
C’est en faisant l’expérience de la mort
dans mon cercle proche
que j’ai commencé à changer.
Au cours de ces dix années d’exploration,
j’ai fait des découvertes
qui ont transcendé mon quotidien
et aujourd’hui
je vais en partager trois avec vous.
On me définit souvent comme un athlète
de haut niveau, un explorateur,
par les exploits
que je réalise au quotidien.
Mais je vais vous raconter
la véritable histoire.
J’ai trois frères et trois sœurs
et j’ai toujours été décrit
comme le plus chétif
de cette fratrie.
Quand j’étais enfant,
rien ne me prédisposait
à réaliser ces grandes expéditions à vélo.
Je souffrais de migraines terribles
quand j’étais enfant,
et qui m’ont isolé des autres enfants.
J’ai encore le souvenir indélébile
des heures passées, les yeux fermés,
à attendre que ces migraines passent
pour pouvoir aller jouer avec mes amis.
J’ai aussi le souvenir
que je disais spontanément oui
aux propositions de mes frères et sœurs,
en repensant à
ces moments de confinement
provoqués par mes migraines.
Vous remarquerez que plus largement,
les enfants entre eux disent souvent oui,
comme une évidence instinctive.
Ils ne pensent pas à la douleur
ou à l'effort nécessaire.
Ils pensent aux jeux
et à la positivité qu’ils génèrent.
Ils osent tout simplement.
En tant qu’adultes en revanche,
réfléchissez attentivement au nombre
de fois que nous disons non au quotidien.
Ce n’est pas possible.
Je n'ai pas le temps.
Je ne peux pas ou je ferai plus tard.
On dit souvent non d’ailleurs,
car inconsciemment,
cela implique des efforts supplémentaires
à fournir de sortir de sa zone de confort.
Toutes ces négations nous enferment.
Alors qu’en disant tout simplement oui
au quotidien,
oui à l’effort,
oui au défi,
vous provoquez naturellement
les ingrédients
de votre propre transformation.
Je vais vous donner un exemple
très simple qui a fait basculer ma vie.
C’était un repas en 2011 organisé
par deux amis qui souhaitaient me proposer
de les accompagner sur une expédition
à vélo pour traverser l’Europe de l’Est.
À cette époque, je me suis surpris
à dire oui sans réfléchir
et cette simple action
a déclenché une réaction en chaîne
tectonique dans ma vie.
Je n’ai ni pensé aux efforts
ni à la douleur que cela allait engendrer.
Et croyez-moi, il y en a eu beaucoup.
Que se serait-il passé
si je leur avais dit non ?
En réalité,
ces expéditions à vélo m’ont appris
que le seuil de résistance à la douleur
que nous avons tous
est une variable qui se travaille
au quotidien.
Lorsque j’ai mal aujourd’hui
lors d’un effort
comme avec de mes migraines hier,
c’est une barrière
mentale que je peux repousser.
J’ai compris finalement, en m’engageant
dans des efforts titanesques,
qu’en multipliant les petits efforts
du quotidien,
en sortant de ma zone de confort,
j’accepte le simple fait
de m’exposer à la douleur
et je lui dit oui.
Et accepter la douleur comme
partenaire et lui dire oui au quotidien
est essentiel.
Aïcha a écrit :
« Une fois que nous acceptons
nos limites, nous les dépassons. »
On me demande souvent :
« que ressens-tu au cours
de ces expéditions extrêmes ? »
L’action de se déplacer à la force humaine
a changé ma vision de l’effort
et du rapport à la nature.
Déployer des efforts physiques
pour rejoindre des lieux fait que
ces lieux prennent soudainement
une dimension particulière
quand vous les atteignez
par vos propres moyens.
Ces moments d’effort extrême
s’impriment dans la mémoire
comme un marqueur
inscrit par mon cerveau.
Non pas parce que le lieu
est exceptionnellement beau,
mais bien parce que
la manière d’y parvenir est singulière
et qu’elle a nécessité un effort.
Jamais je n’oublierai l’image du panneau
Ushuaïa après 240 jours de vélo
pour traverser la cordillère des Andes.
Jamais je n’oublierai le volcan Uturuncu
et son ascension à 5.800 mètres d’altitude
sur l’une des pistes
les plus hautes du monde,
au cœur d’une ancienne mine de soufre.
Jamais enfin je n’oublierai la traversée
de la jungle laotienne, de nuit,
avec ces serpents au sol.
L’accès à la nature rappelle
à quel point nous devons la respecter
et être les serviteurs de ce sanctuaire,
et non les maîtres.
On visualise également
le génie qui y règne.
Cela aide à faire reculer
l’anthropocentrisme de notre époque
où nous vivons dans des lieux clos
et sommes hyperconnectés,
derrière des écrans.
Pour se mettre en mouvement
et se reconnecter à l’univers du vivant,
il est essentiel de quitter nos écrans
et de réserver des moments de vie dédiés
à l’effort en pleine nature.
Se mettre en mouvement, marcher, courir,
pédaler, nager provoque une vibration
et fait naître une sensibilité
dont chacun de nous dispose.
Nous ne sommes sédentaires
que depuis dix mille ans,
alors que nos ancêtres ont été nomades
pendant près de sept millions d’années.
Imaginez une carte au trésor
qui se révèle à vous
dès lors que vous vous mettez
en mouvement.
Derrière un filtre, une vitre de voiture,
d’un bus, d’un train ou derrière l’écran
de votre smartphone, on brouille
cette carte, on n’oublie de regarder
et de comprendre le paysage
pour prendre son selfie.
Dehors, je sais détecter la proximité
d’une rivière avant même de la percevoir,
sentir une situation de danger ou
anticiper un changement de météo,
mais aussi lire les intentions
des humains que je croise.
J’ai appris ceci dans l’effort, sans guide
ni coach, simplement en étant à l’écoute
de mon corps et en lisant cette fameuse
carte dont nous disposons tous.
En utilisant sa propre énergie
pour se déplacer,
vos perceptions changent.
Depuis ma première grande expédition
à vélo, mon rapport à l’effort,
à mes besoins matériels,
a été bouleversé.
C’est ce que j’aime appeler :
le voyage métabolique.
En grec ancien, le mot métabolisme vient
de métabolê, qui signifie changement.
Transformation.
Avoir de l’eau chaude
en tournant un robinet,
de la lumière à toute heure
de la journée
ou un plat chaud en quelques minutes
à l’aide d’un micro-ondes.
J’ai appris que ces assistances
sont une bénédiction du quotidien
mais qu’il faut apprendre
à ne pas en abuser.
Sans effort, nous devenons aveugles.
Et c’est le voyage métabolique
qui permet de rétablir
notre connexion essentielle au vivant.
Le fait de traverser
des endroits de la Terre
où ces assistances
sont parfois inaccessibles,
m’a fait ralentir et profondément
modifier mon rythme de vie.
J’ai changé ma manière de vivre
au quotidien et surtout ma manière
de consommer.
Je suis passé de l’état
de comment avoir plus
à comment avoir
ce dont j’ai vraiment besoin.
C’est surtout ce qui m’a permis
de faire des rencontres incroyables,
en dormant près de 100 nuits
chez l’habitant.
Le déplacement, la force humaine, créent
une empathie naturelle chez les humains.
À vélo je dors rarement dehors,
très souvent accueilli par la générosité
et la bienveillance de mes hôtes.
Peut-être est-ce le souvenir génétique
de nos ancêtres nomades ?
Quelle que soit la culture,
aller à la rencontre des autres à vélo
permet de créer un lien facilement,
comme une solidarité de la douleur
qui fait disparaître les préjugés.
Ce voyage métabolique, je l’entretiens
au quotidien par des gestes simples
et j’applique une mécanique
que tout un chacun peut pratiquer.
Je me déplace souvent à vélo.
Je place la solution de l’effort,
face à celle du confort et de la facilité,
et j’essaye au maximum d’aller
à la rencontre physique des gens
contre celle de la vidéo-conférence.
Cette gymnastique de l'effort, elle permet
de repenser notre manière d'agir,
notre rapport aux écrans,
à l’assistance technologique, mais surtout
ça permet de créer des espaces de liberté
en utilisant son corps comme moyen.
Et utiliser son corps, se déplacer,
s’échapper des écrans
est un moyen essentiel
pour modifier notre rapport à l’effort.
Je vais vous livrer une vérité sur vous
que vous ignorez sans doute.
Nous sommes toutes et tous
des marathoniens.
Nous sommes toutes et tous des sportifs
de haut niveau et des explorateurs.
Nous avons tous été sélectionnés parmi
200 millions de spermatozoïdes pour avoir
la chance d'être en vie aujourd'hui.
Des efforts considérables,
de la souffrance
ont été nécessaires pour que
vous soyez aujourd’hui dans cette salle.
Pourtant, le monde d’aujourd’hui essaye
de nous immobiliser,
de brouiller la carte dont
je vous parlais tout à l’heure,
par le confort, la technologie,
l’immobilité physique,
et surtout l’interdiction de souffrir.
De nos jours tout est instantané,
sans effort, sans risque.
Le café, l’information, le transport
et même le plaisir.
Pourtant, cet abandon
de l’effort a un prix.
Nous développons une méfiance
grandissante à l’égard du risque,
du danger et de la douleur.
En nous connectant de plus en plus
derrière des écrans,
nous détruisons
notre lien avec la nature, mais également
celui avec les autres êtres humains.
Et une énergie gigantesque est dépensée
par des machines
pour nous assister au quotidien,
et ceci au détriment
de la santé de notre planète.
Pour conclure, je citerai un penseur
que j’admire beaucoup, Aristote,
qui disait : « le courage est le juste
milieu entre la peur et l’audace ».
Il est donc temps
de faire face à vos peurs,
de les affronter et de les accepter
et de faire preuve d’audace.
Car votre corps, cette machine formidable
qui a été conçue pour se dépenser
et se déplacer, vous appelle.
Bon voyage !